we're just living in a time
where ai is transforming everything it's
transforming how we work within
disciplines like science or climate
change or medicine or all forms of
technology
it's driving economies worldwide and in
some cases it's leading to outcomes that
perhaps weren't as intended and not as
equitable and beneficial as we would
hope them to be
in this really powerful disruptive
technology there's a lot of good and
opportunity
but there's potential for downside that
we have to just be really mindful of
people are
interacting with and using ai every day
and they don't even know it like youtube
is feeding them up a next video
why that video in my research i know
because i developed these systems i
developed these systems to help people
learn new things i build systems that
help persuade people to take healthier
actions these are technologies that are
influencing the way we learn
our decisions our opinions our behaviors
it is a technology that people use it's
our decisions it's what's causing it to
be applied in the way that it is right
so having people just understand what ai
is that it is a tool for empowerment
it also has the risk of exacerbating
inequality if we're not careful right so
it's a change agent in a way that people
just need to be much more
savvy and cognizant about so they can
make
intelligent informed decisions
[Music]
we created raise which is a new mit-wide
initiative that stands for responsible
ai for social empowerment and education
we're creating these innovative
curriculum that introduce not only ai
concepts and technologies but
responsible design practices as well as
societal implications of these
technologies where the students are
placed as the designer of these systems
in our approach and we educate them in
these methods they build things with it
they design things in groups
how do you make learning experiences
more high touch
more engaging more emotionally engaging
so be able to track the learner's
emotional state their attentional state
adapting the experience and the content
accordingly
innovations around vr ar immersive space
is just other ways
of inventing how we can bring much more
of that
face-to-face interpersonal emotionally
engaging experience to learning at
distance through digital technologies
[Music]